well Christmas is also celebrated in
emilia clarke and henry Goulding's
upcoming rom-com it's actually in the
title and I was exclusively on the very
cool I didn't know that it was going to
be 47 boy yeah I'm not gonna lie there's
like three sort of long johns I'm in
tight it was about 3:00 in the morning
their co-star and the film's writer Emma
Thompson suffered right along with this
I look like a huge avocado pack keeping
this couple warm their mutual admiration
henry was a big fan of Amelia on Game of
Thrones from the get-go going in like
two episodes and I was like I need more
as for Henry on crazy rich Asians well I
think Amelia speaks for all of us and
I've not said this to you because it's
sort of embarrassing she came on the
screen and I was like that sure hasn't
changed in last Christmas based on
George Michaels hit song where amelia is
somewhat down-and-out so my day job is
to work in the Christmas show as no
[ __ ] it's just my general mood and
persona doesn't quite add up
who you to the cherry out that I'm in
that's when Henry interests the picture
that's not very Christmassy we've dialed
it up to like a London you guys couldn't
be making another instance let's not
think ahead why can't we you wrote it I
didn't know I can love Damon Thompson
anymore but I do
[Music]